c'était en
1699 le dramaturge et poète Jean Racine
disparaissait 3 siècles plus tard comme
un hommage Patrice leerrier muni de son
appareil photo empreinte le chemin Jean
Racine sur la commune de manilamo
c'était aussi plutôt mon impression sur
le chemin en 1999 c'était pas du tout
essayer de montrer ce que Racine avait
pu voir comme paysage d'ailleurs dans
certaines photos j'ai introduit des
éléments ENF j'ai j'ai pas intruit des
éléments contemporains comme un poteau
toégraphique ou autre et ça ne me gênait
absolument pas c'était simplement ma
vision sur le chemin en
1999 une réflexion aussi intérieure
quand on se promène comme ça sur un
chemin dans la nature il y a toujours
des idées qui n viennent Patrice
leerrier a lit ainsi promenade et
photographie en 2012 il ressort ses
clichés argentiques qu'il complète de 18
photos numériques en couleur même s'il
reste très attaché au noir et blanc je
trouve qu'il y a une justement un recul
par rapport à ce qu'on photographie
aussi bien pour celui qui fait la photo
que celui qui va la regarder il y a une
certaine distance une certaine réflexion
qu'on peut apporter que moi je retrouve
pas dans la couleur je trouve que c'est
beaucoup plus cru qu'on livre beaucoup
trop de choses au spectateurs une
quarantaine de clichés de la végétation
comme des paysages intérieurs autour du
chemin genan racine est à découvrir à la
maison des bonheurs jusqu'au mardi 2
octobre
I